[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
your tommy
thomas angelo detective normand
detective norman can i join you
sorry for the delay but i didn't want
anybody seeing me
if you know what i mean what can i get
you sir just a coffee
coming right up what can i get you ah
just the coffee
thanks
[Music]
dip your beak no thanks suit yourself
cause i'm on the nut can't even pay for
the coffee
but i got plenty to trade well that's
yours
[Music]
how long you been in dumb
i mostly drove nights because the money
was better it was at the end of one of
those shifts
when i first met paulie and sam
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
get up there's a taxi here we'll be okay
[Music]
move it come on
[Music]
we're through everywhere fast
[Music]
i got a gun pointed at you they catch up
we're dead
but you don't get to walk away i don't
want any trouble
well you got trouble drive how the hell
they knew we'd be there
it doesn't matter now we just got to
lose them how many cars we got following
one for now but there will be more
[Applause]
okay we're close
all over in front of that bar
it's at the aries place yeah that's the
one
[Music]
way here what for you want a little
something from the dawn or not
[Music]
compensation for your services any
damage to your car
this makes us square
i'm sure it's more than enough good
don cilieri wants you to know that he's
very grateful
so if you ever need anything maybe alone
or some honest work don't hesitate to
ask
don doesn't forget his friends yeah okay
thanks
[Music]
jesus how you doing pal you remember me
remember who runs this town make it so
you won't do much walking for a while
look at this guy i ain't thinking make
it fun let's get em
[Music]
right
[Music]
got a handful of nothing christmas
while i'm doing this
look at this
[Music]
how you doing kid
dino lou you got business with the don
now we're just trying to talk to that
cabbie over there that's
all that right yeah
well this is the don's favorite driver
so anything you got to say to him
you could say to me it's
i'll tell you something pal we ain't
leaving empty-handed that's for sure
well then maybe you ain't leaving at all
[Music]
okay then
see your boys around let's go lou
[Music]
thanks at least we could do come on
let's go say hi to the don dan salieri
yeah he's gonna want to hear about this
[Music]
you